contrary to some of the other algorithms
random forest
is actually fairly easy to understand
random forest just merges a collection
of independent decision trees to get a
more accurate and stable prediction
random forest is a type of ensemble
method
ensemble combines several machine
learning models to decrease both bias
and variance
the overall idea here is that multiple
models are fit in each key in the
different aspect of the data
by combining these models ultimately
generate better prediction together than
any of those single models on their own
let's look at a quick example we will
start with what the training looks like
and then we will look at what it is like
to test the model
in training this algorithm will take in
samples from the training data
this is sampling with replacement that
means one
single sample is likely to appear in
multiple different samples
then the next step is to take a sample
of features to be used for each of the
data samples
in the titanic data set if we have seven
features each of these data samples
maybe we'll sample four or five of those
features to be used
so now we have n subsets of our overall
data
and those subsets contain both a subset
of the rows and also a subset of the
columns then with the features in the
data subset
the algorithm will build a decision tree
and try to generate the most
accurate results it's important to
realize that these decision trees are
all developed on their own
they do not know what the other trees
are doing
in summary we would have entries that
are all built independently on different
subsets of data
it's important that these trees are all
independent because you want each
decision tree to key in on different
relationships in the data
this will ultimately generate the best
prediction
next let's look at how the prediction is
generated
each of these tress represent a fit and
concrete model
we would take an example from the test
set let's call it example a
example a will enter into all trees that
have been built and traversed down the
tree based on its features
then each of the entry will generate a
prediction
let's look at the most left-hand side
tree
maybe example a stays at the cabin then
move on to the second layer of the tree
maybe this person pay the fifty dollars
then we move on to the third layer and
maybe this person is a female
based on these features this model will
predict that this person would survive
now the splits and the features on the
second tree will be totally different
so it's possible to get a different
prediction
if we continue the testing you will have
n predictions for example a
one from each tree then the random
forest algorithm will basically just
aggregate all those predictions together
and based on voting with majority rule
you will make a final prediction
in this case it would predict that the
person survived
when should you consider using random
forest
contrary to logistic regression in svm
random forest works quite well for
problems with both categorical
and continuous target variables one of
the major advantage of random forest
is that it has an attribute that lays
out the importance of each predictor
that you're working with
this is really helpful to understand the
relationships and the power of the
features that you're using in your model
hence random forest is great as a quick
benchmark model
it tends to perform quite well it's
relatively fast to train
and it's really quite flexible in the
type of data that it plays
well with on that note when you have
really messy data with missing values
outliers and maybe skewed data random
forest deals really well with that kind
of data
when should we not use this while random
forest is fairly fast
flexible and performs quite well it's
not necessarily likely to be the best
model for any given problem
if you want a quick model that gets you
ninety percent of the way there
it might be the right tool for the job
but if you really need to get one
hundred percent of the way there and
extract all possible value out of the
data
random forest might not be the right
tool
while it's nice to understand the
features and the decision trees on their
own
can be fairly easy to understand when
you have a random forest of hundreds of
decision trees
it can be hard to interpret what's
really happening across that entire
model
so if you need to see the details within
the model random forest might not be the
right choice for
you in summary random forest is
relatively quick to train
but it's not quite as quick to make
predictions
overall random forest is a tremendously
flexible
relatively fast tool that plays well
with different data
and can give you relatively good
performance